ONE.
>> Ed: JOHN ROBERTS,
THANK YOU.
HER>> Sandra: BLASTING CHINA FOR
ITS HANDLING OF THE OUTBREAK.
BEIJING MADE A HUGE MISTAKE IS
YOU JUST TRYING TO COVER UP THE
CRISIS.
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
SUPPRESSING IMPORTANT
INFORMATION.
>> THE FACT THAT THEY KICKED A
JOURNALIST OUT, REPORTING THEY
WERE SILENCED, SHUT DOWN
REPORTING ALL THE KIND OF THINGS
THAT AUTHORITARIAN REGIMES DO.
LIZ’S CLASSIC COMMUNIST IS
INFORMATION EFFORT.
>> Sandra: LET’S BRING IN
CHIEF POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT
FOR THE "WASHINGTON EXAMINER"
ENJOINS US NOW.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THE PRESIDENT’S REACTION LAST
NIGHT AND JUST A MOMENT, BUT
FIRST MIKE POMPEO BLASTING CHINA
AND THAT BRAND-NEW INTERVIEW.
>> REMEMBER, POMPEO WAS A FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR SO HE KNOWS
INTELLIGENCE, HE KNOWS CHINESE
TACTICS NOT ONLY IN THE VIRUS
BUT IN YEARS PAST BUT THEY HAVE
SOME EXPERTISE TO TALK ABOUT.
U.S. OFFICIALS APPARENTLY NOW
BELIEVE THAT CHINA HIT OR
DESTROYED EVIDENCE TO KEEP THE
SEVERITY OF THIS CRISIS A SECRET
FROM THE WORLD.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT U.S.
OFFICIALS HAVE NOTICED FOR A
WHILE.
A SENATOR NOT TOO LONG AGO TOLD
ME THAT BACK IN JANUARY, HE WAS
NOTICING THE DISCREPANCY BETWEEN
CHINESE GOVERNMENT PUBLIC
STATEMENTS, EVERYTHING IS FINE
AND NOTHING TO SEE HERE, AND THE
INCREASINGLY DRACONIAN EFFORTS
THAT WERE TAKEN TO CONTAIN THE
VIRUS IN WUHAN.
THAT MADE HIS EYEBROWS GO UP AND
BE SUSPICIOUS OF WHAT WAS GOING
ON.
SO SOMETHING DEFINITELY FUNKY
GOING ON IN CHINA FOR QUITE A
WHILE.
>> Sandra: WHAT WAS YOUR TAKE
AWAY FROM THE PRESIDENT’S WORDS
LAST NIGHT AS YOU JUST HEARD HIM
SAY HE BELIEVES THAT CHINA MADE
A HUGE MISTAKE AND HE HAS IN THE
PAST WITHOUT RETALIATION.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU ABOUT
THE U.S.’S NEXT MOVE WHEN IT
COMES TO CHINA?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THE IDEA IS NOT
THAT IT WAS DONE DELIBERATELY.
WAS NOT CREATED AS A BIO WEAPON
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT, BUT
CHINA WAS STUDYING THIS VIRUS IN
PART TO SHOW THAT IT HAD A
WORLD-CLASS VIROLOGY CAPABILITY,
AND BY ACCIDENT AND IT GOT OUT
OF THE LABORATORY.
SO THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES THE
UNITED STATES DO NOW?
THE PRESIDENT HAS HAD A VERY
DELICATE RELATIONSHIP WITH CHINA
OVER HIS ENTIRE PRESIDENCY AS HE
TRIES TO GET INCREASED AND
BETTER FOR THE U.S. TRADE TERMS
WITH CHINA.
THERE WERE OBVIOUS THINGS TO DO.
THE UNITED STATES HAS FUNDED THE
VIROLOGY LAB IN WUHAN.
CERTAINLY MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
WHO WANT TO STOP DOING THAT.
SO I THINK THERE WILL BE A
NUMBER OF ACTIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL TAKE.
THEY MAY BE KIND OF OFFENDING
ACTIONS IF CHINA DOES NOT ASK
THINGS ARE COME CLEAN PERHAPS
BECOMING MORE SERIOUS.
>> Sandra: MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
STEPPING FORWARD AS WELL,
TED CRUZ AND TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE BILLS THAT HE IS BRINGING
FORWARD TO COMBAT CHINA.
HERE IS THE SENATOR.
>> THIS WEEK, I’VE GOT FOUR
PIECES OF LEGISLATION I’M
INTRODUCING.
IN ONE OF THAT PROHIBITS THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT FROM CONDUCTING
ANY BUSINESS OVER ANY TELECOM OR
INTERNET INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
CHINA OWNS OR CONTROLS.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY USE IT TO STEAL.
THAT PART OF THE STRATEGY.
>> Sandra: BOTTOM LINE, FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SITTING AT
HOME, THEY HEAR THE PRESIDENT IN
THAT TOWN HALL LAST NIGHT
TALKING ABOUT A HUGE MISTAKE
THAT LED TO ALL OF THIS ON THE
PART OF CHINA, POMPEO CALLING IT
CLASSIC COMMUNIST IS
INFORMATION, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT TO KNOW IF CHINA WILL
ULTIMATELY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
FINAL THOUGHTS.
>> AND SENATOR CRUZ JUST SAID,
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS WHO WANT TO DO THAT.
THERE WERE SO MANY DIFFERENT
PUBLIC CONCERNS ABOUT THIS.
OBVIOUSLY, THE FIRST CONCERN IS
THE HEALTH OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND STOPPING THE SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS.
THE SECOND CONCERN IS REOPENING
THE ECONOMY.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY TAKING
ACTION AGAINST CHINA IS PROBABLY
THE THIRD CONCERN, BUT
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY ONCE WE
FIND OUT WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
>> Sandra: BYRON, ALWAYS GOOD